[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con se cumple un
mes de la toma de kabul por parte de los
talibanes y quiero saludar en este
momento a william splinder el ex
portavoz en américa latina de la agencia
de la onu para los refugiados acnur con
quien vamos a comenzar precisamente
sobre eso los afganos que huyen de este
régimen talibán gracias a william por
estar aquí con nosotros en france24
acnur advirtió que afganistán se acerca
a unas crisis humanitarias de grandes
proporciones y también destacó la
situación incierta de los beckham de los
afganos vulnerables que buscan refugio
fuera de las fronteras de ese país cuál
es la situación de los refugiados tanto
afuera como adentro
cuando la situación en afganistán es
crítica hablemos antes de la situación
dentro del país la situación por la cual
que las personas tienen que salir buenos
años de conflicto han provocado el
desplazamiento de tres millones y medio
de personas
dentro de afganistán esto se complica
con una sequía que afecta a la mayoría
del país y el impacto del cob y entonces
la situación humanitaria dentro del país
es crítica
es esencial que ahora podamos tener
acceso a toda la población para poder
brindar ayuda humanitaria
recientemente se hizo un pedido de
fondos por parte de naciones unidas- la
comunidad internacional se comprometió a
dar mil millones de dólares
estadounidenses a través de diferentes
organizaciones humanitarias incluyendo
la nuestra para aliviar lo más
digamos lo más urgente de las
necesidades humanitarias dentro de
afganistán entonces la situación en este
momento humanitaria es sobre todo
interna es cierto las personas están
saliendo del país como han venido
haciéndolo durante mucho tiempo se
calcula que hay más de 2 millones de
refugiados afganos en países vecinos
como pakistán que irán por el momento
hemos visto que los movimientos de asia
hacia el exterior del país son bastante
reducidos
simplemente porque las personas no
tienen la documentación necesaria para
cruzar estas fronteras ustedes como
organización también hacen un llamado a
los países vecinos de afganistán para
que mantengan sus fronteras abiertas
ante la evolución de la crisis en ese
país pero pakistán al contrario cada día
se pone más restrictivo a la hora de
dejar entrar a ciudadanos afganos por
qué ocurre esto
sí ese es una situación que presenta
muchos desafíos pero antes que todo hay
que reconocer el hecho de que países
como pakistán han recibido durante
décadas a cientos de miles de refugiados
cercanos en este momento hay un millón
cuatrocientos mil refugiados afganos
inscritos
en pakistán o sea el esfuerzo que este
país se ha dado que es el que más
cerebros fugados órganos ha recibido en
el mundo de hecho no durante un año ni
durante diez sino que durante décadas
ese inmenso y eso hay que reconocerlo
ningún país puede solo enfrentar una
crisis de refugiados de esta magnitud
sin el apoyo de la comunidad
internacional por eso es importante que
este apoyo llegue a estos países es
parte del trabajo que nosotros hacemos
es precisamente de abogar de pedir de
explicar las razones por las cuales los
países que han recibido a la inmensa
mayoría de los refugiados afganos
merecen necesitan urgentemente continuar
recibiendo este apoyo y también
obviamente
hablar con las autoridades explicar
también por qué es importante que las
personas que salen por motivos de temor
a la persecución
y que podrían estar en riesgo si son
devueltos a su país tienen que tener la
oportunidad de pedir asilo de encontrar
seguridad en el territorio de todos los
países del mundo y obviamente los países
vecinos son los más afectados
william pero le queremos evitar entonces
cómo van las conversaciones con el
gobierno afgano para llevar la ayuda
humanitaria a la gente que lo más
necesita
bueno acnur está presente en afganistán
desde hace muchas décadas y hemos
siempre tenido
diálogo con los diferentes grupos que
han estado en el poder en el pasado los
talibanes pero también en grupos armados
que controlaban ciertas zonas entonces
hasta ahora nuestra
nuestra acción nuestro mandato ha sido
respetado se nos ha dejado trabajar pero
es una situación difícil que requiere
mucha diplomacia y un constante diálogo
para explicar las razones por las cuales
estamos allí y lo que estamos haciendo
william gracias por su tiempo y por
estar aquí con nosotros en 5 minutos con
de francés 24 vemos una próxima
oportunidad y esta vez los invito a que
continúe con nosotros porque hay mucho
más para ver aquí en nuestro canal
[Música]